hello there I'm John Oliver host of
HBO's last week tonight basically
ballers for weak insecure people we are
off this week but tomorrow is Labor Day
which incidentally is something that you
can call your child's birthday if you
really want to make it all about you
happy Labor Day Landon Oh today marks at
seven years since my body has never been
the same again
enjoy your cake we are all familiar with
the rule that you shouldn't wear white
after Labor Day which is much easier for
some people to follow than for others
Gwyneth but but honestly we should be
using more holidays as arbitrary points
to stop doing things for instance we
should have a rule that after
Thanksgiving you have to stop decorating
your home
with gourds it's cute enough tumba it's
acceptable but obnoxiously focusing in
November but after that you're just
keeping loose produce lying around it's
not better than adorning your front
porch with a bunch of watermelons and
carrot sticks also no drinking eggnog
after December 31st because if you start
your calendar year by consuming a
beverage with the density and
nutritional benefits of molten steel
scrap the rest of your resolutions and
take care of your nog problem now while
we're at it there are some things that
after this Labor Day we should stop
doing and then never do again for
instance let's stop saying that's
interesting when we mean that is not
interesting from now on when someone
tells you a boring story simply say
bless you like you were just sneezed on
because that is what hearing about
someone's travel delay feels like and
while we're at it from Labor Day forward
no more winking ever a wink is a gesture
that is somehow both deeply sexual and
incredibly unsexy like licking a
pinecone
I think I know how you want me to take
that but I am profoundly not on board or
am I see the point is is drugs no more
of that until the end of time we are
back on HP on September 25th until then
good night